-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with Lucy Liu.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it's time for a "Lip Flip."
Here we go.
-♪ It's a lip flip ♪
♪ When you flip your lip ♪
♪ It's a lip flip, yeah ♪
-Hi, everybody.
I'm Lucy Liu, and this is how
I really talk
because I'm from New York.
And when I'm back in New York,
this is how I talk.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Speaks China ]
What's up, Jimmy Fallon.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm the host of
"The Tonight Show."
You can see me every night
on your telly,
and don't forget to watch me
on YouTube.
[ Laughter ]
-Listen up, brother!
Oh, yeah!
I'm in the "Shazam!" movie,
yes I am.
This movie rocks!
So, buckle up muchacho, because
it's going to be shazam!
Bam!
Thank you ma'am!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can't wait to see it.
It's gonna have action
and suspense and fights
and explosions.
"Shazam's" gonna be bigger
and better than ever!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, watch this, Jimmy.
I'm gonna do my Adam Sandler
impression for you.
[ Speaking gibberish ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Speaking Gibberish ]
Shut up!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, also Jimmy, I forgot to
mention that "Shazam!"
has a lot of action
and it's funny,
but it's also really scary.
[ Laughter ]
-Did somebody say scary?
Wah-ha-ha-ha-ha!
-Hey.
I got an idea.
Why don't you start beat-boxing,
and I'll do a "Shazam!"
rap over it?
-[ Beat boxing ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-♪ I like shazam
and I cannot lie ♪
♪ Lucy Liu and Zack Levi ♪
♪ And when those dragons fly in
with a super angry face ♪
♪ Helen Mirren drops
in from space ♪
♪ You'll have fun ♪
♪ Shazam is back ♪
♪ Ha ha ha ha ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
That's all the time we have
for "Lip Flip."
I love you.
Our thanks to our pal, Lucy Liu.
You're the best.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.